Cloud spanner is a relational database
that enables easy scaling of both reads
and writes AS application traffic grows
but making data changes in a relational
database can be tricky
scaling rights on spanner depends
heavily on transaction Behavior
transactions that spend a lot of time
waiting for locks result in high request
latencies which result in slow
applications so it's critical for
developers and dbas to be able to debug
transaction Behavior
to provide visibility into how
transactions are behaving in your
workload spanner now provides lock and
transaction insights let me show you how
it works
foreign
relational databases transactions are
required to ensure that changes to data
are repeatable and consistent
if you have two friends sending you
money the end result should be that your
account balance is increased by the
total that was transferred to you
if you only have a single threaded
application you wouldn't need to worry
about transactions or consistency
but making changes one right at a time
is slow
this is why relational databases have
Concepts like multi-version concurrency
control acid transactions and
transaction isolation levels
many transactions can be running at a
time as long as they're not changing the
same data
Cloud spanner takes exclusive locks to
avoid transactions making changes to the
same value
these exclusive locks ensure critical
data doesn't get lost
locking does mean that transactions may
have to wait their turn to change a
particular value
this weighting results in higher request
latencies
with spanner's lock-in transaction
insights feature you can easily identify
if transaction locks are the root cause
of any slow rights
let's say I am notified from an alert
that my database is experiencing high
amounts of write latency
going into the spanner monitoring
dashboard sure enough there is a high
Spike above two seconds in my 99th
percentile
I validate the period of time this was
happening
clicking over to lock insights I can
confirm that there was an increase in
total lock weight and identify that the
sample game database was affected
the lock weight per row range allows me
to identify the row key ranges involved
in transaction locking ordered by Total
Lock wait time in the selected time
period
this information is pulled from the lock
stats table in the spanner sys schema
it seems that most of the lock issues
come from the player game index
which tracks null values for a player's
current game column and whether the
entry exists in the index
clicking a problematic key range
provides more information about The
Columns that are waiting to acquire
locks
it also shows that these columns are
using exclusive locks as well as both
reader and writer shared locks
clicking view transactions takes me to
the transaction insights page this is
filtered to the transactions that were
causing locks on the lock insights page
here I can identify which transactions
are taking the most time in terms of
write latency
each transaction has a fingerprint based
on the hash of any transaction tags
provided
if there are no transaction tags the
operations involved in the transaction
make up the hash for the fingerprint
I have three transactions listed but two
potentially problematic ones that are
over 200 milliseconds in the chart
one spikes with higher latency and then
reduces at the end the other is less
latency but shorter lived
I can drill in to get more information
about each one
the first transaction has a high abort
count indicating deadlocking issues
this is due to concurrent requests
attempting to assign the same players to
different games
the second transaction doesn't have any
aborts but High latency
this transaction is writing to most of
the columns of the players table so this
transaction is inserting new players
another interesting finding is that the
latency reduces at the end of this
period this was because I stopped the
transaction that assigns players to
games
so I have found the root cause of a high
right latency there are two issues
assigning players to games creates a lot
of deadlocks
and secondly assigning players to games
causes higher rate latencies for adding
new users
now I can go about making a plan to
solve these issues in my application
if you are experiencing high right
latencies in your Cloud spanner database
long transaction logs just might be the
reason
these locks can be a bottleneck to your
ability to scale rights on spanner
with lock and transaction insights
locking issues in your workload can be
quickly identified
once identified changes can be made to
the transactions or schema to remove the
bottlenecks
go ahead and give Lock and transaction
insight to try let me know in the
comments below if this helped you to
remove lock contention in your spanner
workload
thank you